dr. strange your work saved the lives of
thousands what if I told you that
reality is one of many you are probably
the most intense librarian I have ever
met in this film what was your approach
to creating Wong's presence in this film
and at Komara tache
well I you know looking from the source
material and wanting to move away those
certain aspects of tea making men serve
and finding out how can we create a walk
of our times
he's also the drill sergeant this
librarian who's not your average
librarian that you know overdue books
find with broken fingers this is our
Wang that we don't mess with that
serious nature as he understands the
severity that lies ahead and you are Wow
just one like Adele now I know you guard
the artifacts but if you could choose a
sling ring or an eye of agamotto or I'd
go for the of agamotto I think yeah be
careful which path to travel down
strains stronger men than you have
bucked away
a particular element of your costume
that got you into character yeah it's
not just you it's the whole team that
brings you together costume plays a
great part as soon as it's they start
kind of suiting you up then and then
you're carrying a little wand of watoomb
you know everything starts kind of
channeling and it's great you know
there's that real sort of in a big kit
well the inner kid and you go this is
great we gotta do this for a living so
we're for volume on this collection
should be stolen you'll be dead before
you ever left the compound any late fees
I should know about maiming perhaps